I did not hit her it's not true it's
bullshit I did not hit her
I did not oh hi mark I love my eyes
that's what time
you
welcome back to another hilarious 'ti it
is hilarious 'ti Sunday last weekend was
retro rewind I talked about tremors tons
of fun but in the spirit of DC Comics
and their past mistakes let's talk about
Supergirl they actually tried to make a
mini DC Universe back in the day
incorporating this into the Christopher
Reeve universe they didn't do it right
this film begins with some very shiny
opening credits that were clearly
inspired by Richard Donner's opening
titles for Superman the movie now I
didn't remember much about Supergirl I
had seen some of it on TV as a kid I
didn't really remember much about this
movie re watching it though I was
absolutely blown away to discover that
Peter O'Toole is in this movie and he
plays a character named Saul Tarr what
is this space ghost coast to coast I'm
expecting Brack to show up telling jokes
and moult are to be over on the keyboard
deejaying this whole thing for us and
while Peter O'Toole is in fact an
excellent actor his performance in this
movie is horrendously over-the-top I
don't believe you how in that through
that and we're now introduced to
Supergirl and she seems almost like a
child like a baby almost like she's
experiencing things for the first time
she's amazed by everything she sees it's
almost like she was just born five
minutes ago quite literally actually
Zoltar is showing her some kind of
wizardry with god-awful visual effects
and this movie's insane people I mean it
gets really trippy it really does she
starts bringing to life a dragonfly with
some sort of wizardry that kind of flies
around and then she almost gets sucked
out into the void of space because the
barrier surrounding their little world
rips and this barrier is plastic
I mean it's plastic don't tell me that
that's some kind of Kryptonian armor
shield or some bullshit that's plastic
Zoltar is harnessing something called
the omegahedron
he keeps calling it that apparently it's
the thing that powers their city because
when that thing blasts into space
Supergirl just without a second thought
hops in some sort of spacecraft after it
and we
the necessary exposition where her
parents inform us that this omegahedron
device powers their entire world they
will lose everything without it without
it the City Council by more than a few
days I likes will grow dim in the very
air we breathe so fin so after this
exposition heavy horrific Li inept
opening I'm terrified watching this
movie the other day preparing for this
review I actually got chills down my
body in the worst possible way realizing
that I was about to watch a two-hour
film that thought that was the opening
to hook me and oh my god these visual
effects are amazing no they really suck
actually they're pretty terrible so back
on earth we meet Selena played by fade
done away she's the main villain of this
entire film she's a witch and she has a
friend who explains how to become
invisible take five black beans on the
head of a dead man
place one bean in his mouth two beans in
his eyes oh my god this is going nowhere
good do these people find the Omega head
drawn because it landed on earth of
course where else would it land and this
thing apparently can do anything
it is the all-powerful device that can
accomplish everything ever so what is
the Omega hedron do everything cool cuz
then nothing has to make sense and I can
just do whatever I want
screenwriting so Supergirl lands in the
water and she just bursts out of the
water in full costume just as Supergirl
right there she's just instantaneously
Supergirl what an interesting character
I mean I really care a lot about this
character that I know nothing about now
if I thought the film was bad already
this is what gets even worse she picks
up a flower and uses her heat vision to
make it bloom is this because she's a
girl
Superman's heat vision can kill but
super girls heat vision can make flowers
bloom so she soon realizes that on earth
she can fly and for whatever reason they
decided to make this very artsy it's
like the independent artsy version of
Supergirl flying with all these
incredibly shitty shots like behind
branches I'm still having a hard time
getting over the fact that there is no
attempt to even remotely explain why she
is Supergirl this film just expects
everyone to have seen Superman the movie
and with that knowledge we now know that
girl from this place is Supergirl
because she's a superhero in this
screenplay makes no sense I mean none
and we will get into more reasons why so
she runs into two rapists because of
course they're just rapists walking
around looking for Supergirl
and after she explains that she is in
fact Superman's cousin and uses her
super breath to blow one of them away
this guy pulls out a knife and he's
ready to fight and then she uses her
heat vision on the knife and it works
correctly this time earlier it made a
flower bloom this time it actually works
the way it's supposed to and despite
that happening he still challenges her
and I'm like dude this is not a good
idea for you you're dumb so back to Faye
Dunaway as Selena the witch in this film
every scene with her is just her
discussing world domination that's all
her character is of course I mean what
else could they possibly have done
because every villain just wants to rule
the world such a pretty world I can't
wait until it's all mine I'm considering
nothing less than world domination now
this is where the film lost me entirely
earlier I wasn't invested but I was at
least watching it this is where I'm not
kidding I almost turned it off I'm
serious I almost was like screw it I'm
not doing this video she sees some girls
in school uniforms and she decides to
adopt said school uniform and go to this
school for no reason her entire world is
in jeopardy do you remember what her
parents said without her the City
Council five more than a few days unlike
to a girl gym in the very air we breathe
so thin yeah like her whole family and
all her friends they're all gonna die
and she decides to go to school she's
here to find the omegahedron thing why
is she going to school so let's talk
about a and W a and W they gave him some
money
they yes a and W was like hey Supergirl
you like root beer don't you
and then the one attempt to in some way
create a universe with the DC movies of
the 70s and 80s she finds a picture of
Christopher Reeve that is all they could
do I understand the Christopher Reeve
had originally planned a cameo in this
movie but more than likely this smart
talented man was like no your script is
ass so this is when the witches like
start their big evil plan and their
scheme is to cast a spell on some hunky
guy so that this man can just like be
their servant how devious and by the way
this guy's Ellis from die hard now I
know why he was addicted to cocaine in
that film around this time in the movie
I realized this film has no narrative
there's no plot
there is no thorough line of a story
it's just random shit over and over
again here's some witches they're trying
to cast a spell on Ellis from die hard
oh here's Jimmy Olsen here's Supergirl
just going to a school so these witches
then use black magic to cause Ellis to
be chased by this thing and by the way
I'm just going to keep calling him Ellis
because I don't even know what his name
is in this movie and I don't really give
a shit this causes a gigantic bloated
Looney Toons Domino piece extravaganza
word like one thing will knock over into
something else which knocks over
something else which causes something
else to roll around this was their idea
of a set piece I guess in this scene I
noticed something this place little
chapel of roses this was also in the
earlier scene with the rapist people and
they not have permission to film in more
than just like one location so Supergirl
saves the day I guess I don't know she
did something and people didn't die and
then there's this really crazy line that
just really I was like this whole movies
weird but then this this just doesn't
make any sense at all just just watch a
storm dragon
a Supergirl a storm dragon what does
that mean I mean it like I actually I
care more about learning what that means
then I do about even finishing this
review right now what the fuck does that
mean who is that girl I don't know a
scroll G of burger go what is that girl
I don't know what's black ado what is
that girl I don't know ask a gobble
juice guy like who wrote so Selena's
black magic curse doesn't work because
the first girl that Ellis sees is
Supergirl she was originally supposed to
be the first girl that he saw Selena and
that didn't work out so now Ellis is in
love with Supergirl and this is our
movie I'm serious
this guy's under a spell to be in love
with Supergirl and he follows her
everywhere and super girls like no no
so since she isn't really into this guy
she apparently decides to experiment and
thinks I'm just gonna go try to kiss
myself in this mirror why it's like what
is this what's happening this movie's
crazy people is always crazy so Selena
casts another kind of spell and now the
wind is after Supergirl that's right
this movie did it before the happening
she confronts this invisible force
because there's no other villain for her
to fight so I mean it might as well be
the wind so she grabs a lamppost flies
into the storm and lets lightning strike
at a whole bunch of times and then she
like uses it like as a weapon hmm
it's the thing none of this movie none
of it okay none of it none of it works
now I actually wrote in my notes there
right here I stopped the film to see how
much longer I had and I still had fifty
more minutes so now it's Selina versus
Supergirl and I'm telling you these
effects are laughably awful there's no
tension
there's no stakes I honestly want to
turn it off I hate it I hate it I hate
watching this movie it's so bad I know
you're thinking well do Chris you know
order Hillary also you're supposed to be
entertaining guys there are different
types of hilarious E's I've said this a
billion times
there's guilty pleasures there's movies
that are so bad they're good and then
they're movies that are so hilarious
that they even got made and Supergirl is
that movie and still I must remind you
isn't her entire world and everyone she
loves and cares for in danger of dying
without her the City Council five more
than a few days I likes will go dim in
the very air we breathe so fin don't
worry guys she's on earth discovering
love and going to school everything's
gonna be fine
know you're all gonna die actually so
next Supergirl decides to eat a coconut
why did I say I would review this so I
guess the spell on Ellis gets broken but
he still really loves Supergirl anyway
yay and then Selena with the flick of
her wrist and the omegahedron creates a
mountain this mountain just appears in
this small town and everyone's like hey
there's a mountain that's weird huh
that's strange
now back to our everyday lives
Supergirl flies up to the mountain
confronts Selina and some
Selena traps her in the Phantom Zone for
like five seconds before she arrives on
cheap-ass version of Mordor within a few
minutes there is already an uprising of
people in this town including a picket
line against Selina for this mountain
this movie is broken this thing is more
broken than Superman 64 this thing is
fucked and when Supergirl wakes up in
this cheap-ass Mordor she gets scared by
a skeleton that reminds me of an earlier
line she said I am car of Argo city
daughter of Alura and zor-el and I don't
scare easily
apparently you actually do what a great
script so Zoltar shows up he's trapped
there - Selina then captures all the
principal characters because we need all
of them to be captured so the Supergirl
can be Supergirl and Zoltar is obsessed
with this squirt thing he keeps talking
about it over and over again and it's
really disturbing me I mean it it's
disturbing the shit out of me squid
squid
what is he talking about if he wants her
to have a drink just say would you like
a drink
quit calling debts making me have goose
bumps is disgusting like what is he what
is he saying I hate it I hate that that
is the most annoying thing I think I've
ever heard in a movie that line forget I
mentioned it have a squid instead I hate
it so much that annoys the shit out of
me what is that why why can you just say
do you want to drink quit calling it
that sure you won't have a squirt oh god
that's so annoying there's this really
awkwardly long sequence inside of a
swirly Red Tornado because apparently
that's the way you get out of the
Phantom Zone because the place where you
get trapped in forever of course has an
exit saltar dies and just just look at
this shot just look at it just just
stare at it and look at it now think
about the fact that I had to watch two
hours of this
so Supergirl gets really mad and just
instantaneously flies out of the Phantom
Zone and arrives at Selena's house
Selena starts then like rumbling the
floor she uses her spells or magic or
whatever to make the floor Rumble and
tumble like an earthquake Supergirl can
fly why is this affecting her adversely
all she has to do is float up she can
fly
I just wanted Peter Pan to zoom in the
window and say this to her
because if she would have been like oh
yeah I can fly I forgot so the power of
shadow or something like appears and
starts stretching Supergirl like she
Stretch Armstrong this looks
unforgivable I'm serious like the whole
movie before you really like oh I looks
really bad right here it's just like
what
why would you do that why would you even
make this why would you even release
this just be like oh sorry we lost all
of our film reels we can't release
Supergirl sorry that would have been the
better choice
so she overcomes that and just like
turns into a tornado and sucks
everything up you don't even get the
sense that Supergirl actually did
anything she just turns into a tornado
and just sucks everything up and she
went so bad so the mountain just
disappears with no explanation of course
I've grown used to not having anything
make sense and she flies underwater into
her ship and goes back home I guess and
you don't get to see her family saved or
anything like the whole stakes of the
movie was her family dying and like her
city died and what was this movie about
she went to school
I think people liked a A&W Root Beer
oh my god I thought Superman 4 was bad
that's my review of Supergirl
I'm very sorry my dear you were done
poorly this is a much nicer this version
mmm so put you there guys that's my
Hillary asti review of Supergirl I hate
it that might be my least favorite DC
Comics movie because it was just so bad
like Batman and Robin's bad steal with
Shaquille O'Neal these are both
hilariously reviews I've already done
those are bad movies but they're funny
at least Supergirl is just atrocious it
really is a movie they should have just
been like whoops we lost the real sorry
we're not going to release it but as I
promised I would let you guys know what
next week's retro rewind is going to be
continuing in the vein of DC Comics
related things that are crappy I thought
next week's retro rewind could be oh I
don't know maybe a discussion on
something really terrible maybe a past
experience something traumatizing it's
definitely not going to be a review for
Superman 64 so definitely don't look
forward to a retro rewind of Superman 64
I am definitely not going to try to beat
this game on camera definitely don't
look forward to that next week you're
the best thank you so much as always for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck my nice